[Musique]
le nouveau maire ump du havre s'appelle
edouard philippe
il a 40 ans issu d'une famille havraise
son arrière-grand-père était dockers il
prend la succession d'antoine ruffenach
démissionnaire le jeune élu veut allier
continuité et modernité pour marquer son
mandat edouard philippe bientôt 40 ans
père de trois enfants ne compte pas
perdre de temps pour s'approprier sa
mairie sa nouvelle équipe et son nouveau
bureau
antonin concerne d'euros totalement vide
enfin est donc libre il faut que je
bouge pas de marque et ça commence en
musique
par contre travail de la musique c'est
comme ça ça me en fait ce madame
concentré de l'eba portrait type de
musique un énarque et ancien magistrat
le nouveau maire a commencé dès le
lendemain de son élection à faire la
tournée des services près de 3000
personnes travaillent pour la mairie on
se vaccine peut-être qui fonctionne
plutôt bien et ça vrai plaisir de
rencontrer tout le monde pour d'abord
pour présenter parce que nous avons
beaucoup qui ne connaissent pas et puis
aussi pour dire que j'apprécie ce qu'ils
font donner un petit peu quelques
directions sur ce qu'on va faire l'amour
parmi ses premières sorties la
bibliothèque salacrou le jeune maire
auteur de polars à 16h veut rendre le
livre encore plus accessible là où on ne
l'attend pas j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse
en sorte
voiron soir regardez comme une ville
dans laquelle des gens qui n'aiment pas
encore rien peuvent découvrir ce plaisir
peuvent découvrir ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire dans ce plaisir de la
lecture
donc on va essayer de mettre en place un
certain nombre d'actions de renforcer
les actions déjà engagées
mais peut-être d'en inventer de
nouvelles comme par exemple des livres
disponibles dans le futur tram mourir et
loire philippe devra aussi se faire
connaître élu depuis 2001 son visage
reste encore peu connue des havrais son
programme pour suivre les grandes
orientations d'antoine ruffenach est
parmi les plus compliqués donner corps
et consistance au grand paris
nous avons une chance historique à
saisir avec ce dossier du grand paris
c'est vraiment une chance alors ce sera
pas l'oeuvre d'un mandat sera pas
l'oeuvre d'une minute c'est vraiment
l'oeuvre d'une génération et moi je suis
convaincu que si toutes les forces
havraise mais plus généralement de
l'agglomération de la région s'y
consacre on peut faire du havre et de la
région normande impôts de développement
pour la france entière tournée vers le
commerce mondial et maritime le nouveau
maire du havre à plus de 3 ans jusqu'aux
prochaines municipales
trois ans pour séduire une ville qu'il
sait foncièrement de gauche
[Musique]